escribamos el número 0.8 0.8 como una
fracción a ver aquí el 8 está en el
lugar de las décimas o sea que tenemos
ocho décimas y que es una décima pues
una décima es uno entre diez y si
tenemos ocho entonces tenemos ocho
décimas
o sea que 0.8 es igual a ocho entre diez
aquí ya lo escribimos como una fracción
pero pues podemos simplificarlo todavía
más ambos números y el numerador y el
denominador son divisibles entre dos
entonces vamos a dividir los dos entre 2
y pues no vamos a afectar esta fracción
porque estamos dividiendo entre dos
tanto el numerador como el denominador o
sea en realidad lo que vamos a hacer
8 / 2 / 10 / 2 y esto cuando es igual
pues 8 entre 24 y 10 entre 25
listo 0.8 es igual a 8 decimos que su
vez es igual a 4 quintos